على كل من القاهره ينضم لنا صانع المحتوى
محمد اشرف محمد يسعد صباحك منورنا في صباح
العربيه اهلا بك
صباح الفل صباح الفل على كل الجمهور بتاع
البرنامج
نفسه كيف يعرف نفسه للجمهور
لان هي اهم حاجه الصراحه عملتها وهي اللي
ادت لكل الحاجات الثانيه يعني انا بدات
تستنى الكوميديا ومنها اتشافت واتعرفت
وبدات بقى اكتب في حاجات في برامج
ومسلسلات واشتغلت في الاعلانات برده عن
طريق الاستاند الكامري دايما بحبك
اكتر حاجه بحبها يعني
محمد انت اغلب اسكتشاتك عن الجواز ايه
مشكلتك مع الجواز
بس هي الفكره كلها ان انا اي حاجه في
حياتي بتبقى جديده علي
بطلع منها او بشوفها بشكل مختلف
فالفكره كلها انا كانت مشكلتي مع الجواز
في البدايه ان انا يعني ما كنتش بساعد في
بيت اهلي قوي وما باعملش حاجات كثير قوي
في البيت وكده وفجاه طلب مني اساعد بقى في
حاجه اسمها مشاركه ما كنتش اعرف عنها حاجه
مشكله
تمام الحمد لله يعني
قبل ست سنوات كان تجاربك ستاندر كوميدي
يعني الصغيره ومحدوده بعدين انتشرتوا صار
لك جمهور واسع يعني حدثنا كيف حتى نجحت
توصل لك هذا الجمهور العريض
الاول كانت واحده واحده كده في البدايه زي
ما انت قلت كده الحفلات كانت صغيره وكنت
بطلع اجرب قدام جمهور قليل بيبقى مثلا 30
او 40 واحد
وكان الاستاندر الكوميدي في مصر عامه ما
كانش له شعبيه كبيره قوي لسه فاا في
الموضوع كان صعب قوي في البدايه يعني بس
احنا كنا مكملين وفضلت اعمل حفلات
استمريت يعني لحد 2019
2019 عملنا فرقه
احنا سبع كوميديانز انا وطه ووليد ومصطفى
عباس ومحمد حلمي احمد خيري عصام
من ساعتها والحفلات بدات تكبر بدا جمهورنا
يكبر لما يعني لما اشتغلنا مع بعض على
الموضوع كفرقه الموضوع بقى يكبر اكثر
واسرع والحمد لله بقى في ناس كثير جدا
دلوقتي في مصر تعرف الاستاند الكامري كويس
جدا عارفين وكده يعني فالموضوع كده يعني
هلا مقطع لعبه الحبار شاركت فيه وهلا بس
هذا اللون مثل السكويت جيم قصدي
لا لا ههه
الحلقه دي انا الحلقات اللي كانت
اللي هي بتاعه الدنيا الملعونه او العروسه
اه
انا في انا في الاول خالص انا كنت بشتغل
في حاجات كثير قوي يعني جنب الاستاندر
كوميدي طبعا ما كانش بيجيب فلوس كثير قوي
فكنت بشتغل بقى حاجات كثير جربت نفسي في
حاجات كثير جدا فلقيت ان انا فشلت في
حاجات كثير قوي كلها ما نفعتش ولقيت ان
المشترك بينهم كلهم ان انا بعرف اتريق
عليهم يعني او على او على المشاكل اللي
بتحصل لي في الشغل وكده
فكان نفسي بقى اشتغل في حاجه اللي هي
علاقه بكتابه المحتوى ان انا طالما قدرت
ان اعمل ستاند رقمي والناس بتضحك فعلا انا
باقوله فحسيت ان انا يعني اقدر اعمل كده
اقدر اكتب محتوى وبتاع فهمم بدات ادور في
الشركات الاعلانات تبعت ناس كثير جدا لحد
ما في احد همم شاف
الرساله
وكان اسمه محمد باشا واتفرج على فيديوز
ليا استني واعجبته جدا وضحكته يعني همم
[موسيقى]
بما انه انت كاتب كمان هل اغلب الممثلين
بيعبروا عما يشعر بهم محمد لحظه كتابه
السيناريو ولا في ممثلين خذلوك
يعني بيضيف للي انا كتبته يعني بيخليه
احلى معظم الصراحه يعني في ناس كتير بتعمل
مجهود كبير
وابقى انا كاتب مثلا حاجات معينه يا اما
بتتقال زي ما هي في دماغي فعلا زي ما انا
كاتبها فببقى مبسوط جدا يا اما بيزود من
عنده حاجه او تفصيله معينه او طريقه
بيقولها بيخلي الموضوع احسن كمان فبيخليني
ابقى مبسوط اكثر اللي انا كتبته يعني اممم
و نحن مبسوطين بوجودك معنا وبنتشكرك كل
الشكر شكرا محمد اشرف صانع المحتوى من
القاهره